it stretches for nearly an entire block
on Broadway
okay welcome and entering zabars is a
symphony for the senses
there's house roasted coffee beans
freshly baked bread
Savory knishes yes baby Smoked Meats to
make your mouth water and smoked fish
that's to die for I have a very jealous
brother son everybody right now
it's good stuff so good it's good stuff
David zabar grew up inside the store
that he helps run today so people call
it Novi Nova Scotia sound basically it's
a mild cured smoked salmon that is crazy
thin slicing we work with the smoke
houses you know for how we want it you
know it's a fatter fish it's less salt
and so that they give us a selection of
what we want for our customers wow thank
you sir keeping those customers happy is
what keeps them coming back to this New
York Institution
so good and a philosophy passed down to
David from his father Stanley and Uncle
Saul who inherited Zabar's from their
father Louis it's a history detailed in
the book zabars a family story with
recipes published this year
it begins with a harrowing escape from
Australia Ukraine where the well-off
Louisa Barca lived until 1920 when his
father was murdered by Bolshevik troops
inside the family home one of numerous
programs that forced many Jews to flee
Europe at the time in 1922 Louis landed
in New York City shortened his name to
zabar and reunited with the woman he'd
marry his sister's childhood friend Lily
titlebaum he found work as a grocer
according to the book Louis slept in a
storage room behind the store at night
saving until he could rent a counter
inside a store selling smoked meat and
fish in 1934. we never knew the details
before three generations of zabars told
us they knew little of Louie's Escape
son Saul and Stanley spoke of his work
ethic my father was a tough he was
working hard he or wanted Saul to be his
right hand man
and soft I didn't want anything until
until he died well at odds until he died
because he was demanding of me things
that I didn't want to be yet when Louis
died at age 49 Saul and eventually
Stanley along with their longtime
partner Murray Klein helped lead zabars
through years of expansion Saul buying
the fish and introducing specialty items
like coffee well before Starbucks
Stanley overseeing the deli counter and
the financials as President and Vice
President Saul and Stanley are still
involved in the business today I didn't
mention I'm 94.
you don't look it at the moment I'm only
90. exactly
as Nora Ephron showed in her 1998
rom-con You've Got Mail navigating your
way through a crowded zabars can be a
challenging experience I mean this is
the best Tour Ever it helps when you
have someone who knows their way around
this is why you don't need to cook in
New York yeah we make and package
everything Stanley gave us a rare look
inside Zabar's vast kitchen this is
behind the scenes truly and introduced
us to a few of their 200 plus long time
employees how many years you've been
working here
2 25. our shopping continued Stanley
insisting on Sarai bread with a slice of
rye bread for me one more seeds and
regular I mean Jeff and Michelle if
you're really nice I might bring you
some of these so or I might use them
myself but not before I get a tip from a
friendly Shopper Stanley's wife Judy
look I mean he's just loading me up
much better than these but you're
steering me wrong Judy got me right
gotta get the bake
Stanley well the story of zabars may be
extraordinary it's also one of many that
combined narrative is told at a
traveling exhibition welcome to I'll
have what she's having the Jewish deli
Jesse kornberg is the CEO of the
skirball cultural center in Los Angeles
where it originated this is footage from
1900 and this is from the Lower East
Side of New York and when you think of
deli food you are talking about the
flavor of preserving food industry these
are the Hebrew letters that Spell Kosher
in Yiddish right slowly over time Kasha
varnishkas chopped liver what would be
considered Deli began to change you know
salmon is not native to Poland
Bagel was not happening this is a
thoroughly American story by the
mid-century Jewish delis could be found
throughout the country catering to new
customers this is the moment where that
slice of Swiss cheese goes on a Reuben
sandwich because somebody's tasting it
and they're not keeping kosher and they
want it Delhi so mainstream the pop
culture on rye section highlights some
of the many times it's been center stage
in TV and film including the iconic
scene which gave the exhibit its title
yes oh God
I'll have what she's having it works if
you know the reference and it still
works if you're not familiar because I
definitely want to have some of what
you're having exactly curators Kate
Thurston and Laura Mart got the idea for
the exhibition over a notch like this we
met at the Museum's Cafe which was
transformed into Judy's Deli it's really
interesting to consider where this food
came from and how it connects us to
history and Heritage whether that's our
heritage or the heritage of other groups
that we share this country with it's a
connection found in the Zabar's family
story written by Stanley and Judy's
daughter Lori she passed away three
months before the book was published her
daughter Marguerite mariskal reflected
on her mom's inspiration she really
wanted to create something that we could
all look back on and do it at a time
when we still had these two you know
incredible men running the store at the
end of her book Lori writes a Century
after my grandparents immigrated to
America their legacy continues I like to
say that zabars is the longest running
show on Broadway
Zabar's New York royalty now we don't
feel that way no we do have quality but
it's some kind of nostalgia it's also a
piece of New York this space is precious
you know people say you're a custodian
of the Tabernacle like we are guardians
of a Sacred Space and I hope we all
maintain our commitment to keep it that
way